you want to go airbnb i don't know we
can touch it real quickly you want to go
for it why don't you leave it with
airbnb go yeah okay so they're going
public
um they have an ipo coming up and the
their revenue has dropped 72 percent up
up until june their last
filings their revenue is down 72 this
ipo is going to have them valued at 30b
30 billion you know what i don't like
airbnb i don't like the idea of going
into somebody else's house
i think it's weird i think it's creepy
um i
you know if you dig a little bit deeper
on this story the one of the reasons
they're going
to the ipo is because they had promised
a lot of their executives their stock
options and they're going to expire at
the end of the year or
you know six months or whatever so
that's kind of leading the way so some
of these initial guys that have worked
for a b and b
can get out and make their money same
thing and plus they've been borrowing
a ton of money lately just to keep
afloat i think
it's a bad business model i don't think
going forward people want to stay in
other people's houses i've looked at
airbnb online
i don't like it i mean you're looking at
these rooms they're creepy i mean
it makes no sense have you ever stayed
in an airbnb i think i have one time
i have one time it wasn't a great
experience i i prefer hotels nice hotels
by the way
and here's my last thought on this um
adam take it from here no you were you
were killing it you're
gonna say something or no i think i got
distracted i was thinking about
something else
uh oh yeah here's my last thought i mean
it makes you think that these
ipos are just rigged for the investment
bankers
and the people that have access to get
in on it to make money it's not so much
that they think
this is a huge play for the future
period
um yeah i i've used airbnb i've
i've been i've done it in london i've
done it in paris i've done it in rome
i've done it in amsterdam i've done it
in new york no we're asking
we're asking where you've stayed at not
who you've done where hey
you said you've done it and all these
things it's a family show here i've done
it in all these places
well that's so that's probably have you
used airbnb before yeah well yeah
hello okay got it yes i've stayed in
airbnb some of us english is literal you
know we think when you say done
let me tell you something um adam
bragging about mario adam's bragging
about every single time he has to brag
about the women in his life there's my
boyfriend mario
he would kiss mario he just said it
specifically i said i wouldn't not put
money on that the guy's very uh enticing
but i'll give you an example i mean we
obviously
i know tom is not a fan of airbnb but
there's millions and millions of people
who are using airbnb
i'll give you a case example we know
where uh shout out to the big
biz doc who used to do case examples i
went to amsterdam i was with a
girlfriend of mine at the time
and a buddy of mine is like i'm getting
a hotel it was 400 bucks a night
for a very decent hotel
very just decent hotel you had a little
shoe box
i was with me and my girl for like 200
bucks a night we had a sick
apartment in amsterdam sick half the
price
two bedroom ridiculous spot there was
nothing creepy going on
it was like it was just a dope spot so
if you can save money and stay in a
better spot
a lot of this isn't like five years ago
or just like
you know i don't know what's good like
they got made service they're coming in
there
there's people who do this very
professionally so you can
what happens is like just like in amazon
you can see this is a five-star rating
this is a four and a half star
this is a two-star all right if it's a
two-star ain't staying there but if it
has a
four-star four and a half five-star
rating the place is
do they sick and you can get it for half
the price of what a hotel here's here's
my biggest problem with it you know you
get on a plane right now and you get
these people that take out their wet
wipes and they they wipe everything down
you know the tray table the whole thing
how are people feeling comfortable going
into somebody's house
now in covet i think it's a terrible
idea for the ipo for this country just
may or for this company
it just makes me think that's what it is
isn't that the exact same thing of being
in a hotel room
like there's multiple multiple multiple
people being in a hotel much different
the cleaning staffs in the hotel
but they what my point is they do have
cleaning staff at airbnbs
i know they may but it's so many people
that can
go on airbnb and have their house rented
out right there's only one person at a
time in a hotel you can have dozens and
different random people
if you go to a hotel that hotels you
like you could have literally a hundred
different people staying in a hotel
in that same bed in a given month but an
airbnb proper cleaning
one person each one you don't know
you're not listening they have made
service and they have their
they have cleaning services that come in
and clean the airbnbs
and this is why they have ratings just
like you go in a hotel like i'm a big
fan of hotels.com you go on hotels.com
you can see all right i'm gonna get this
hotel
oh this is a five-star hotel sick i get
a good deal oh there's a two-star hotel
i'm out i'm not staying there
so airbnb has seen what the hotel
industry has done they've stepped their
game up
this is clearly why people millions of
people all across the world
embrace airbnb i think airbnb is here to
stay yeah so
you guys can hash it out on what you
want to stay when we travel next time
but uh
airbnb tom won't be staying anywhere tom
you're going to be sleeping in a hotel
bed that literally
is shonda comfortable with airbnb or no
are you guys on the same page with that
no she's very comfortable with a luxury
hotel okay god yeah all right so she's
you got something i'm comfortable with
what shonda says we're staying tom says
when it comes to travel i call the shots
there oh that very good that's
respectful okay so
uh airbnb brought in 2.5 billion dollars
in revenue in the first
nine nine months of the year this year
down from 3.7 billion
last year so they're down 1.2 billion
they took a hit
uh it's net loss more than doubled
during the period to
697 net loss net loss 697
and they're going at a valuation of what
30 billion dollars you're talking about
10 times their top line
12 times their top line revenue not even
12 times their net profit
they're not even profiting and they're
going at a 30 billion dollar valuation
marketplace this tells you
the public market right now it's
interesting when people are going out
there and from the june 30th in a three
month period their revenues dropped 72
percent so
the market apparently is saying look we
don't care if you're not making any
money or not we're still willing to
value this thing at a
30 billion dollars and if they can get
away with that and do it look more power
to them if they're going to get it where
people are willing to buy their shares
at a price like that
more power to them i just think right
now uh i don't see that business model
doing too well
anytime soon but again we'll see what's
going to take place with airbnb
uh and their numbers there honestly
during a pandemic places
things like i mean the hotels are
getting crushed it's not like they're
killing these they're getting cameras
it's not like the airline industry is
doing well none of these industries are
doing well right now by the way you may
have a pandemic you mentioned biz dock
and amsterdam
bisdog probably knows more about the
products that people use freely in
amsterdam than anybody you've ever met
him in your life he could do a case
study
on weed like no other from the professor
standpoint shout out to our buddy there
with uh
his math was off in pennsylvania but
we'll cut him off
wasn't off on pennsylvania something
happened that night when we went to
sleep we don't know what happened
they called counting the votes we don't
know what happened that night we don't
happen hundred percent they counted was
on one side apparently a hundred percent
of
to canada was on one side but we will
find out here soon